con el profesor Hiroshi Ishii.
Construimos esta configuración
de 512 electroimanes.
Juntos podían mover objetos
sobre su superficie.
Pero el problema con esto
era que los imanes
cuestan más de USD 10 000.
Si bien cada uno era bastante pequeño,
juntos pesaban tanto
que la mesa que los sostenía
empezó a ceder.
Yo quería construir algo
que permitiera este tipo de interacciones
sobre cualquier superficie de mesa.
Por eso, para explorar esta idea
construí un ejército de pequeños robots
y cada uno de estos robots tiene lo que llamamos omniruedas.
Son ruedas especiales
que pueden moverse por igual en cualquier dirección,
y cuando se dota a estos robots
de un videoproyector,
se obtienen estas herramientas físicas
para interactuar con información digital.
Este es un ejemplo de lo que quiero decir.
Esta es una aplicación para editar video
en la que todos los controles
para manipular el video son físicos.
Si queremos retocar el color,
entramos al modo color,
y tenemos 3 diales
para retocar el color.
Si queremos ajustar el audio,
tenemos 2 diales para hacerlo, con estos objetos físicos.
Aquí los canales izquierdo y derecho están sincronizados
pero si queremos, podemos sobrescribir eso
agarrando ambos al mismo tiempo.
La idea es conseguir la velocidad
y la eficiencia de usar estos diales físicos
junto a la flexibilidad y versatilidad
de un sistema diseñado en software.
Y esta es una aplicación cartográfica
para respuesta a desastres.
Uno tiene estos objetos físicos
que representan la policía, los bomberos y el equipo de rescate,
y un despachador puede agarrarlos
y ubicarlos en el mapa
para decirle a esas unidades dónde ir,
y entonces la posición de las unidades en el mapa
se sincroniza con la posición
de esas unidades en el mundo real.
Esta es una aplicación de videochat.
Es increíble la cantidad de emociones que se pueden transmitir
con pocos movimientos simples
de un objeto físico.
Con esta interfaz, abrimos un enorme abanico de posibilidades
entre los juegos de mesa tradicionales
y los juegos de arcade,
donde las posibilidades físicas de interacción
dan lugar a muchos estilos diferentes de jugar.
Pero una de las áreas que más me entusiasma
es el uso de esta plataforma
en problemas difíciles de resolver
para computadoras o personas por separado.
Un ejemplo es el plegamiento de proteínas.
Aquí tenemos una interfaz
para manipular las proteínas,
podemos agarrar las asas
para tratar de mover la proteína y plegarla de distintas maneras.
Y si la movemos en una forma que no tiene sentido,
con la simulación molecular subyacente
obtenemos esta respuesta física
y sentimos estas asas físicas
que nos empujan hacia atrás.
Así, sentir lo que ocurre
dentro de una simulación molecular
es un nivel totalmente diferente de interacción.
Apenas empezamos a explorar
las posibilidades de usar software
para controlar el movimiento
de objetos en nuestro entorno.
Quizá esta sea la computadora del futuro.
No hay pantalla táctil.
No hay tecnología visible, en absoluto.
Pero cuando queremos hacer un videochat
o jugar un juego
o diseñar las diapositivas para nuestra próxima charla TED
los objetos de la mesa cobran vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)